je travaille moi
alors tu es prêt à voir Baffie en
chirurgien ah je suis prêt ouais je
m'attends à tout avec ma fille avec la
fille
[Musique]
là
on va prendre un litre vous êtes où
parce que là il va y passer là vous êtes
frugalise ou pas
de problème c'est une question
un bout de gros colon il me faut j'ai
besoin de fabriquer un anus artificiel
en kit donnez-moi un bout de colon à
bout d'un test
de quel groupe sanguin c'est pas une
prise de sang
mais je vous demande pas de le donner je
vous en donne de le donner madame venez
avec moi venez avec moi c'est une
question de vie ou de morgue
vomir rien de vous voir
oui venez avec moi on fait juste une
petite ablation il y en a pour 5 minutes
il faut absolument opérer tout de suite
vous êtes de quel groupe sanguin s'il
vous plaît vous venez avec moi je fais
un petit transfusion là mais venez avec
moi j'ai un client mais madame il va
mourir mais j'ai loupé la porte pourquoi
mais je vais lui claquer d'aborder
un petit peu parce que j'ai mon
assistante qui est parti simplement vous
êtes mignonne
elle est partie déféquer et puis comment
elle est un petit peu sur les nerfs il y
en a pour 20 minutes au moins merci
comme ça vous êtes mignonne merci je
vous appelle tout à l'heure pour faire
pipi voilà vous êtes de quel groupe s'il
vous plaît vous êtes de quel groupe
sanguin
s'il vous plaît
est-ce que c'est un chien on va pas le
laisser crever quand même j'ai
rendez-vous là
d'accord il y a pas de problème il a
perdu un testicule avec quoi pour le
remplacer
tu sais reprendre un bout d'intestin on
va vous prendre un bout d'intestin
mais si en comme une paupiette on va
faire comme une paupiette l'animal comme
ça il sera pas défiguré
dépêchez-vous c'est un berger allemand
super ce sera vraiment con qui y passe
allez venez monsieur un berger allemand
vite vous a dit même groupe sanguin un
berger allemand et alors c'est mon chien
va pas le laisser crever non
[Musique]
le transexuel c'est vous venez vite on a
le bonheur là venez vite on a on a
l'andouillette là ça vaut le transexuel
c'est pas vous
monsieur et merci d'avoir choisi
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu